We all invite you to come to Slovenia and explore our lakes,...
...and we would be happy to provide you our escort and service.
I'm from Putnik in London...
...and I'm here on a swimming holiday in Slovenia with my mum.
She's a really keen swimmer.
And so she was really keen on doing this.
And I'm not such a strong swimmer,...
...but you know, I swim a bit and then get in the boat.
And the view everywhere, it's lovely.
Would you tell your friends how beautiful Slovenia is?
It's absolutely beautiful. It's incredible, stunning.
It's fantastic.
Yeah, I swim in salt water at home.
And so I really like the idea of coming to the Slovenian lakes to swim in the fresh water.
The water is so pure and it's the right temperature too.
And the itinerary that we've been on has been really, really good too.
In over three days, we've done three lakes and a river.
It's peaceful, it's quiet, it's calm, it's incredibly clear.
And it's just the best place to swim.
It's amazing to be in between the mountains.
I'm accustomed to the pool which is always the same thing.
This is incredible.
This is really good.
You should all try it.
It's worth it!